Recommendation systems are
used in many different areas
other than movies.
Jeff Bezos, the
CEO of Amazon, said
that, "If I have 3 million
customers on the web,
I should have 3 million
stores on the web."
The internet allows for
mass personalization,
and recommendation systems
are a key part of that.
Recommendation
systems build models
about users' preferences
to personalize the user
experience.
This helps users find items they
might not have searched for,
like a new favorite
band, an old friend who
uses the same social media
network, or a book or song
that they're likely to enjoy.
Recommendation systems
are a cornerstone
of these top businesses.
Social networking
sites, like Facebook,
music streaming sites, like
Pandora, and retail companies,
like Amazon, all provide
recommendation systems
for their users.
Both collaborative filtering
and content filtering
are used in practice.
Collaborative filtering
is used by companies
like Amazon, Facebook,
and Google News.
Content filtering
is used by companies
like Pandora, Rotten
Tomatoes, and See This Next.
And Netflix uses both
collaborative filtering
and content filtering.
So now let's go back
to the Netflix prize.
29 days after last call was
announced, on July 25, 2009,
the team The Ensemble submitted
a 10.09% improvement, beating
the 10.05% improvement that
was submitted by Bellkor's
Pragmatic Chaos to
signal last call.
But by the time Netflix stopped
accepting submissions the next
day, Bellkor's Pragmatic Chaos
had also submitted a 10.09%
improvement, and The Ensemble
had submitted a 10.10%
improvement.
To really test the
algorithms, Netflix
tested them on a
private test set
that the teams had
never seen before.
This is the true test
of predictive ability.
On September 18, 2009, Netflix
announced that the winning team
was Bellkor's Pragmatic Chaos.
They won the competition and
the $1 million grand prize.
Recommendation systems
provide a significant edge
to many companies.
In today's digital age,
businesses often have hundreds
of thousands of items to
offer their customers,
whether they're movies, songs
, or people they might know
on Facebook.
Excellent recommendation
systems can make or break
these businesses.
Clustering algorithms,
which are tailored
to find similar customers
or similar items,
form the backbone of many of
these recommendation systems.
Clustering also has many other
interesting applications.
In the next lecture,
we'll see how clustering
can be used to improve
the predictive ability
of classification methods.